[Musique]
du jazz toujours plus de jazz le style a
la cote dans le département à notre
festival lui est dédié pour en parler
mélanie poquet bonsoir ça pour votre
chronique coup de coeur culture où nous
emmener vous ce soir on part à
maisons-laffitte du 14 au 23 juin c'est
le 14e festival dédié à ce style
cette année onze concerts sont
programmés avec en ouverture un concert
événement au château de la ville vont se
produire pour l'occasion trois artistes
reconnus sur la scène internationale
le guitariste sylvain luc le batteur
nicolas viccaro et le bassiste richard
bona
écoutons un extrait d'un live de ce
dernier
[Musique]
maman découvre qu'en vivant
nouveau
et c'est un festival mais là nous tirons
aussi chaque année des hommages didier
lockwood l'an passé cette année le
public pourra redécouvrir les notes de
michel petrucciani
le pianiste et compositeur français
décédé il ya tout juste vingt ans un
musicien à part dans l'histoire du jazz
et des précoces prolifique à l'hommage
sera rendu le jeudi 20 juin à la salle
malesherbes au piano laurent coulondre
très marquée par le jazzman alors la 14e
édition du maisons laffitte jazz
festival débute le 14 juin prochain
d'autres artistes vont bien sûr rythme
et les différentes dates de concert et
pour les écouter et les découvrir
direction le site du festival
merci mélanie d'autres actualités
culturelles dans votre émission 7 après
le journal le 7-8 culture